bonjour vimy merci bonjour à toutes et à
tous et bonjour marie françoise bernard
cinsault gpa tranquard gruger banques
dites r oui alors effectivement on vous
invite dans le cadre des 40 ans de le
cee le au seo ou le cs vous nous direz
parce qu'il ya deux appellations
mais d'abord il faut préciser que vous
êtes docteur en littérature et
civilisations du monde anglophone vous
connaissez bien la caraïbe d'ailleurs
physiquement vous êtes vous avez
beaucoup voyagé dans dans la caraïbe et
vous êtes l'auteur on le rappelle il y a
deux ans d'un ouvrage consacré justement
à l'eau c'est est-ce d'ailleurs intitulé
le cs en 10 questions
voilà alors donc effectivement le ocs
l'organisation en anglais organization
of eastern caribbean state ou os et aux
donc parlant de la caraïbe orientale
quand on dit le ceo donc est née d'une
du traité de basse terre à saint kitts
qui a été signé le 18 juin 1981 donc
1980 2021 il ya 40 ans est-ce que
c'était dans l'esprit que l'union fait
la force surtout pour les micro états
que constituent ces îles de la caraïbe
orientale à la règle de l'est absolument
dans les années 60 les pays les grands
pays de la caraïbe ont acquis leur
indépendance et les sept petits
territoires se sont retrouvés un peu
isolé on va dire par rapport aux
territoires qu'ils avaient des
ressources minières ou qui avait un
héritage colonial beaucoup plus
important géographiquement pour que pour
qu'elle comprenne bien
c'est un peu la différence entre le ce
qu'on appelle les grandes antilles et
des petites antilles eve parler vite
pour vite parce qu'on va exclure de dans
les pays de la caraïbe de l'est on va
exclure la barbade et et
trinidad-et-tobago qui sont de grands
enfin de grands territoires ou même si
c'est une petite taille pour la barbade
mais c'est quand même un pays qui avait
jeudi un héritage colonial puisque c'est
la plus ancienne colonie de la grande
bretagne
donc elle avait ce qu'on appelle la
préférence impériale qui lui accorder
des avantages que les autres n'avaient
pas donc la barbade qui jusqu'à
maintenant a sa propre monnaie donc vole
de ses propres ailes on va dire trinidad
et tobago aussi donc qui sont dans la
caraïbe de l'est mais qui néanmoins ne
font pas partie de cet organisme
organismes mais qui sont associés
fantômas aussi en tant que membre du
cari commun d'accord alors donc le
c'était le 18 juin 1980 on le rappelle
la signature du traité mais les
festivités pour ainsi dire en tout cas
les événements qui marquent les 40 ans
de cette hausse et au donc organisation
des états de la caraïbe orientale a
commencé le lancement officiel du
programme des festivités c'était il y a
deux jours le 15 mars exactement le 15
mars donc le premier ministe de la
dominique et en ce moment le président
de la haute autorité de cette
organisation
ce spirit et a lancé les festivités donc
en proposant le programme jusqu'au mois
de juin donc corps jusqu'au 6 juillet en
fait donc depuis 15 ans
des manifestations ont commencé virtuel
moi j'entends parce que dans ces temps
difficiles de crise sanitaire
toutes les manifestations sont
virtuelles sur soi sur la page facebook
soit sûr
les la chaîne youtube donc les
festivités ont commencé par un événement
qui est la messe d'action de grâce parce
que tout commençait par une baisse de la
caraïbe orientale ce qu'ils voient là
une 5e la caraïbe tout court d'ailleurs
alors marie françoise bernard cinsault
il faut donc préciser que le cs ou le
haut c'est au compte onze états membres
aux états membres c'est ça alors on va
les énumérer rapidement alors alors a
les yeux peut y aller donc en fait on
nous partons des îles vierges jusqu'à
jusqu'à la grenade
donc si on suit l'archipel des antilles
on a des états qui sont de plein droit
les sept états de plein droit ce sont
les états indépendants et les états
associés ce sont ceux qui sont non
indépendant donc on va pour les quatre
associés on a la martinique et en
guadeloupe
les anguilles à qui n'est pas encore de
la grande bretagne et les îles vierges
britanniques
donc c'est un territoire n'étant pas des
états souverains
donc ils sont membres voilà départ parmi
les quelques membres
je dirais de droit en tig antique
bahreïn la dominique la grenade
montserrat sainte lucie sainte lucie
saint kitts et nevis sang et les
grenadines
oui la dominique jeudi saint vincent et
les grenadines et donc les îles vierges
britanniques
voilà c'est ça et anguilles à la
martinique et la guadeloupe vous avez
dit et puis un quatrième dont les îles
les îles vierges britanniques sont comme
anguilles ad encore des partenaires de
la grande bretagne donc sont des états
associés d'accord saint-martin et on
passe on va devenir membre associé
dossier oui voilà
vu les relations avec
là la guadeloupe donc ce matin est
demandée est de fait membres associés
mais je parle plutôt de la partie
hollandaise martin qui est l'os est
parti aussi devraient être associés
parce que ce n'est pas un état souverain
le seo qui donc fête ses 40 ans en cette
année 2011 21
deux exemples de réalisations majeures
dont ses 40 ans qui ont été faits par
l'océan oui la première chose c'est la
monnaie commune alors c'est c'est une
monnaie à taux fixe donc qui ne se
dévalue pas en fonction du dollar
puisque le tory fixe et qui est
justement qui a été à l'initiative du
prix nobel de l'économie sur apple et
oui ce prix nobel de sainte-lucie donc
c'est lui qui est à l'origine de la
réflexion qui a été menée sur cette
monnaie de manière à ce qu'elle soit
facteur de stabilité dans cette zone
donc la première c'est celle ci et je
veux dire la dernière parce qu'il ya
tellement de choses réalisées entre
temps la dernière c'est la libre
circulation des biens et des personnes
et qui est en train de se mettre en
place avec un passeport commun ou ecs
avec des des règles d un cadre
réglementaire pour que ces personnes
puissent étudier travailler et se
distraire les voisines
alors parlons maintenant avec vous marie
françoise bernard cinsault docteur en
littérature et civilisations du monde
anglophone on le rappelle l'auteur
il y a deux ans de ce livre le seo le cs
en dix questions pour la martinique avec
ce statut de membre associé enfin
guadeloupe et martinique
quel traitement nous est réservée est
puisqu'elle est fait pour nous aussi
parce que bon le haut c'est au cela
parle pas encore à beaucoup de personnes
chez nous et on a le regard beaucoup
tourné vers l'europe
d'ailleurs le au seo a signé un traité
avec l'union européenne n'a pas que
saignant signé un traité en fait le
partenariat en europe caraïbes existe
depuis les accords à cp depuis très
longtemps donc ce n'est pas une
nouveauté
seulement en raison justement de
l'intégration de la martinique et la
guadeloupe à cet espace les relations
avec l'union européenne ont pris 1
un tournant en fait un don qu'on a dans
les à l'eau en apparence vous dit qu'on
ne voit pas on ne voit pas parce qu'on
ne fait pas de publicité autour de ce
qui se fait mais alors mais depuis 2014
et surtout plus régulièrement depuis
deux ans même si la crise annie terrab
je pense à un peu voilé tout ce qui se
passe il y a énormément des changes qui
se font entre nos deux territoires et la
caraïbe environnantes
je vais j'en veux pas oui oui j'en veux
pour preuve je vais donner deux exemples
par exemple le programme élan dont vous
avez entendu certainement parler qui est
un programme destiné à améliorer la
mobilité entre ces pays
la mobilité professionnelle la mobilité
apprenons que la mobilité des élèves la
mobilité des professeurs de formation et
de même que la potiche à l'apprentissage
des langues parce que je pense que c'est
le premier la première barrière à faire
tomber dans le schéma de l'intégration
c'est la barrière de la langue
donc il y a deux aspects l'aspect
apprentissage de la langue anglaise
et puis à l'autre aspect l'aspect
valorisation du créole puisque les deux
ils sont françaises francophones sont
sollicités par exemple là pour
l'application de poule à l'apprentissage
du créole à l'école dans les îles
voisines dominique et sainte lucie
donc il y à une coopération
universitaire qui se fait aussi via élan
avec la production d'ouvragés de
documents pédagogiques etc
donc il y à un échange intense qui se
fait j'ai participé par exemple moi même
à un salon virtuel de la formation
professionnelle organisée par élan et le
psg aussi participé à ce qu'ils ont
appelé ici ssd m c'est un sommet sur le
développement durable ou en martinique
toutes les personnes qui avaient quelque
chose à dire sur le dow et c est sous la
caraïbe de demain pouvait s'exprimer
dans un salon virtuel
donc il y a énormément de choses qui se
font je pense qu'elle gagne
elle gagnerait à être plus connu est
effectivement et y compris pour nous les
médias faudrait peut-être que de temps
en temps c'est un plus souvent un regard
vers notre carême voisine vous avez
raison cela dit c'est vrai qu'avec les
technologies actuelles on peut faire
beaucoup de choses comme vous dites en
virtuel mais il ya aussi la limitation
quand même des déplacements à la fois
maritimes et aériens ça ne facilite pas
les choses quand même pour les relations
entre ces îles proches
alors bon pour l'instant vous savez les
mêmes les conditions sont les mêmes pour
le monde entier on n'a pas la situation
est la même au mont d'or maudites en
dehors du contexte je pense que les
choses sont relativement aisées
dès lors qu'on accorde de l'intérêt à ce
qui nous entoure parce que je n'ai
jamais été gêné dans mes déplacements de
la caraïbe j'ai trouvé les places de
bateaux qu'il fallait il ya un an il y
un transport maritime entre toutes les
îles depuis récemment depuis l'année
dernière
ferry on peut partir de martinique
l'arrivée jusqu'à trinidad par ferry
depuis un an à peu près donc les choses
évoluent et comme de plus en plus
l'avion est boudé pour des raisons de
développement durable donc l'accent est
mis sur ses déplacements par voie
maritime
et puis je vais juste dire que par
exemple on sait comment tiny qu'il y à
un lycée de la liste des métiers de
l'ariège qui on passe de voir le jour
il est adossé à une autre un autre
aspect justement des fonds européens
pour cette région et pour l'intégration
dans cette zone le crop qui est un
projet fed qui permet à des fonds
européens ont permis de développer les
relations
enfin dans la mer des caraïbes
donc je pense que avec toute cette
synergie européenne caribéenne et
martiniquaise on peut arriver à voir
évoluer les transports voilà voilà
et vous avez raison de signaler
justement la jeunesse de parler de
l'avenir parce que parmi les les
événements contenues dans le programme
des festivités des 40 ans de l'océan il
y a justement
je le donne à titre d'exemple lancement
d'un livre scolaire construire ensemble
un guide sur l'intégration régionale
dans le seo
donc voilà un manuel scolaire en anglais
mais il y aura peut-être une version
française donc à sensibiliser le public
et notamment le jeune public sur les
actions de l'organisation et puis le 6
juin 2021 est prévu également
l'assemblée de la jeunesse de le hausser
au donc voilà le regard est tourné pour
ses 40 ans vers l'avenir et la jeunesse
et vous même quand vous avez publié ce
livre
le cs en 10 questions marie françoise
bernard cinsault votre intention c'était
disait que nous nous référons
majoritairement modèle européen ici en
martinique mais que vous souhaitez
démontrer aux martiniquaise martinique
que nous avons intégré une organisation
riches dont nous avons beaucoup à
apprendre je vous cite là donc c'est ce
que vous disiez
voilà donc deux mots sur le rendez vous
de demain parce que l écrivent des
antilles un seuil en prolongement de la
journée de la 2 de lutte pour les droits
des femmes du 8 mars et demain donc
l'association nicea présente quatre
écrivains francophones et leur
engagement alors il y aura ni colle cage
wydad amrani que justin joseph et vous
marie françoise bernard quelques mots
pour conclure alors donc la maison
interculturelle des écrivains et des
littératures en amériques caraïbes c'est
le nom de la miss est là c'est une
association qui ont dernier à la mep
demain jeudi à 18 heures donc une table
ronde avec quatre écrit et 4 écrivaine
que vous venez de prise de cité et nous
avons toutes contribué un ouvrage de
nicole calfan recueil logis dont une
trentaine de femmes une trentaine de
femmes ont collaboré à cette route c'est
trouve âge et quatre d'entre elles donc
dont moi nous serons présentes pour
montrer la nature de nos écrits et la
façon dont nous écrivons en étant ancré
dans la caraïbe
voilà et justement on s'est un peu plus
lointain mais le 7 mai également
à trinité je crois c'est ça vous allez
présenter justement votre livre le
seysses en dix questions pour
l'association des amis de san fernando à
trinidad adolescente fernando trinidad
oui alors donc la ville de trinité
jumelée avec fernando trinidad et à pour
fêter justement notre vie caribéenne
nous allons célébrer donc ses 40 ans de
l'eau au cs en présentant l'ouvragé donc
je serai présente à 18 heures alors
quand même le 7 mai donc c'est un peu
lointain on y reviendra l'occasion
puisque les quarante ans ça ça va durer
encore quelques semaines il y aura des
échos bien sûr sur nos antennes et sur
notre site internet à propos
jimmy de ses 40 ans de l'os et aux
voiles à l'organisation et les états de
la caraïbe orientale